all right Ken hello I play Amnesia you
play ammunition yes I grow a beard you
grow a beard oh yeah okay yeah sure but
for ones you bested me the first time
ever you had a child before me I will
give you that can I thought you was
gonna say you have a kid I have a kid
that's like wait a minute
I'm finally part of that game yes
how many how many kids do you have now
Ken do you even care yeah I'm starting
my own Like A League of Legends team so
one more right are you gonna have a
esport team yeah you're not even gonna
play okay I'll just be the coach
thinking they can take care of it I love
that okay well because of that finally I
can laugh at uh child memes for the
first time ever yay
So today we're gonna react to uh
children Meme and I will finally
understand the joke all the time I've
been fake laughing this whole time it's
true nobody gets dad jokes until they
become a dad then you're just like wow I
didn't think I could laugh this much
how's it possible starting off oh by the
way this is Martina curated she sent me
all of these so we'll see uh what she
got
sorry I shouldn't swear right away
shame on you what are those reflexes he
did a cartoon fall
yeah be careful with your language
because one day your child will
literally repeat everything you say all
of it I was listening on some bad some
not child appropriate stuff I guess I
was listening to a podcast I'm just like
you can't listen to that in front of
Bjorn they're swearing way too much
they're saying bad things it's not that
they'll just repeat what you say they'll
repeat what you say to strangers
somebody completely you've never known
and they'd be like my dad wiped my bum
today and you're like I sure did hop on
buddy yeah
tell me you're a married couple that
just put your kids to bed without
telling me
ah silence I need to reply to all these
messages no one says anything no one's
cuddling everyone's just like
[Laughter]
that was stressful
I get it now but it's just pain it's not
even like a do you want to watch
anything there's just no there's nothing
here you just said hold on one second
Mary's yelling outside the door hold on
I gotta hold a baby for a minute you
know what if this was old me I'd be like
what the look Felix kids don't care
if you're about to record a video that's
going to get millions of views
[Laughter]
are you there I am I am bad sorry about
that how dare you have a child I would
never do such a thing I know right shame
on me jeez
[Music]
it's like hang on a minute that's very
cute
very much yeah
oh you get to go through like the
terrible twos and the three neighbors oh
no I've heard about it no it's like
right that moment where they learned
like a little bit of like freedom but
they they're still limited by their
little baby selves oh so frustrating
isn't it funny though it
yeah but in the moment you're just like
oh my God
please yourself no you can't why are you
so mad at me for that
you're trying to do something for the
new one yeah
[Music]
I also need to do other things
this skill I've gained from the one hand
actions my God I I done things I didn't
know what was possible one-handed
everything man yeah everything I can't
do old baby stuff that I can't do with
one hand I just change it out get rid of
it I'm useless to me like I get like the
backpack the baby carrier and strap them
to you oh yeah we do that yeah yeah for
sure yeah that's pretty good yeah yeah
but yeah seriously like you set them
down to do anything it's like oh my
stomach oh I shouldn't ate that I get to
the bathroom and your baby's like Father
the Betrayal you come back and he he's
gone like tiny tears now running down
his face oh I'm I'm so sorry I I had to
go to the bathroom for two seconds
that's it
the cookies are good
yeah
[Music]
especially when there's put everywhere
as well come on oh you still got the
little bitty baby too wait until they
get a little stronger and they're just
like oh God they get stronger
he's already so powerful well it really
bothers me as well is the poops they
don't get smaller no no it's already bad
enough oh well
don't tell me I don't I don't wanna okay
interrupting video to announce an
historical day they said it wouldn't
come but he did first of all as a
newborn parent I want to give my
sincerest thank you to the one that
stood by my side throughout all of it my
love my passion my best friend G fuel
thank you g fuel but there's been one
thing about G fuel that has always
bothered me and you fans when we
announced the first G fuel cup yes it
looked incredible ecstatic but we could
only print a pattern on a smaller piece
of the cup and everyone thought you have
this pattern you should go all the way
around the cup and G fuel said I'm sorry
that's just not scientifically possible
we can't do that and I've been praying
ever since please there's gotta be some
new advanced technology to print the
pattern all the way around G feel please
it can't be done but today through high
level spell casting the G feel Wizards
have managed to do it veggie fuel Shaker
cuff goes all the way around the
greatest birth of all time sorry dude
but it gets even better you're not ready
for this there's an stainless steel
version
g-fuel is the greatest energy drink of
all time PewDiePie Ling on Berry flavor
is the greatest flavor and if you buy
the aluminum one you get five of the
most popular taste packs PewDiePie
lingerberry flavor obviously included do
you feel it's like a secret energy hack
you get any of that afterwards which is
which is more than ever
it's filled with vitamins and zero sugar
and none of that other engines drink
literally out well just make you good
you're good I feel good suits on here's
the deal I'm gonna cut you guys a deal
take a seat listen up for an extremely
limited time only the next 48 hours you
will get 33 off go I'm not gonna be able
to have time to tell you twice but in
case you were late and you're like ah
damn it you still get 20 off but I will
shame you a little bit but you can still
go 20 still good deal and if
at the checkout to get the 33 or 20 you
also compete to win a Nintendo switch
overlay bundled with a Legend of Zelda I
don't remember the title so use the code
or get Shame Shame I'll hold it back for
now but I will use it thank you g fuel
for saving my life and let's go on with
this video you don't need it Sakai
that's a pastor you have when he was a
baby in oh my God
how dare you insult me with these I
think when they're so young like they
know they won't take them but eventually
our kids started liking them but we do
we do it to where we only give it to him
when it's nap time it's like almost like
a treat not like something they need all
the time that's good parenting tips
[Music]
God damn they spit out so much it
doesn't matter in burp or whatever
technique people say yeah yeah oh my God
dang it and then they're like I'm hungry
and you're like yes
it's like they finally finished and
everything is perfect and then they're
like oh food in my mouth I would like
more of that food in my mouth thank you
now please I won't wait
I'm not your ubereats oh dude
oh no
he's gonna be a YouTuber he's got their
reactions down that's what you have to
play through the same part of the game
the second time because your footage
failed oh
[Music]
wow I didn't see that kind of thing I
play horror games for years and somehow
still get scared from them I didn't see
it coming
oh what the hell is this
oh
yeah awesome puppet okay of course you
might see a sense this this cursed
creepy
baby
oh God stop it no yeah marxit loves to
like I'm trying to share photos of
bieran and I'm like do you have any cute
ones and she loves to take like ugly
pictures of him you know when you do
like the lowest focal length on the
camera and really close up and you look
like insane like I don't know
this one
I always feel like they are whistling
when they do that though I'm like what
are you humming boy what you working on
there oh there's this great point of uh
when they're two maybe you can teach
them things and they're just happy that
you're happy so if they do something
like yeah then they'll do it over and
over and over again so you can teach
them just like he does like this little
thing he goes yeah like poinsetti like
he's like yeah what's up and so every
time I come out of the office and he
sees him he's like yeah look at him good
he thinks it's hilarious my brain just
went to like oh he's taking out the
trash yeah man you did it well you could
do that too like you can walk the floors
ahead yeah
dude you're so sick clean up your plate
when you're done eating and they'll like
bring it to you and you're like yeah
thank you and they'll do it until they
get to about four and then like wait a
minute
it takes them two years to realize
it free laborers all time
it goes from like yeah do it to do it
because I said so
oh here it comes
[Music]
oh oh God oh God they don't crawl like
that do they oh god ah what the hell is
that demon no well you know not every
baby learns how to crawl the same it's
unfortunate our first kid Layla she had
like a Quasimodo crawl that she would
like sit down in like one hand like
scoot across the floor at you what the
hell I didn't
know I thought they all like
yeah
what the they figured they figured
out eventually but sometimes when they
learn to move in a certain way they just
kind of keep doing it
come on feed me come on come over here
Jesus Christ
what the hell it's like the ring you
know when they lose their jaw oh my God
that's terrifying oh my God
[Laughter]
geez look at him go
damn
this is just so he can have his own time
he's you're trying to yeah I feel like I
know where this is going
[Music]
yeah there it is
fine yeah oh of course of course of
course yeah thank you march very good
memes very nice very least all right
switching over to my memes that I've
gathered this little guy was ready to
fight
a little bit
once again
this little guy was ready to fight
what mate you what you do that again
mate
this reminds me have you noticed that
your uh your baby just randomly feels
like he's fallen and freaks out from
time to time for no reason yeah what is
uh I'm trying to told me what it was but
I forgot but I always imagine it's like
they wake up and they realize they're
not in the womb anymore and they're like
what the my
of all time no nothing
foreign
[Music]
and you brought it you reminded me of
this lady no yeah apparently she made an
apology I didn't I didn't know she did
that have you so did she no did she
dance I understand Maybe
with the video that was me just trying
to be positive what do you think about
that Ken she was being positive I'll
tell you what I think about that
now that I'm a dad I can finally answer
this question would I slap him for 100
billion
yes yes absolutely
I would slap that baby for 100 million
years well that was uh that was really
fun yeah we're watching memes with Ken
check out Ken's Channel yay if you
haven't already for some reason and mine
112 million please can we hit it and
I'll see you guys in the next one did
you know thousands of data Brokers have
secret shadow profiles of you and they
include a frightening amount of details
online privacy data is our currency and
some of the buyers are actually in the
business of selling your data over and
over again
it's really surprising to me how
companies can take your private
information sell it and somehow that's
legal this information can be used by
scammers strangers insurance companies
Banks businesses even the government and
they can all use this information
against you while also making a good
profit out of it where's my money my
money apparently my email address is
worth 89 to any brand I want that 89 the
good news is you can remove it the bad
news is it will take you over 300 hours
to do so opting out of this has been
made Difficult by default and that's
where incognit comes in all you got to
do to get your personal information
removed is sign up pay a small bit
amount of money and sit back and relax
and let incognit do the work
it's a really great service and I
recommend you guys check it out to
protect your privacy incognit will take
care of it all for you and you can track
it easily online and I know what you're
thinking Felix just sounds great can you
cut me a deal though of course right now
if you go to incognito.com PewDiePie you
get 60 off from what I can tell it's a
very competitive price if you guys use
the offer so I recommend taking
advantage now so click the link below to
get your personal information wiped off
the internet as it should have been from
the beginning thank you Incognito for
sponsoring this video